in my life as a professional engaged in
the business of education I frequently
find myself involved in conversations
about college and career-readiness
almost always that phrase college and
career-readiness
precedes a conversation between two
people both of whom went to college a
particular kind of college even and the
conversation is usually about college I
think our society hasn't been serious
enough about the career part of that
equation there is a presumption among
some people that the body of knowledge
necessary to be ready for college-level
work and the body of knowledge necessary
to enter a career with prospects for
promotion are exactly the same I believe
that there are students in fact the vast
majority of students whose education
after high school will look nothing like
mine I left my public high school in
South Carolina and moved to
Massachusetts and went to an Ivy League
university and spent four years there
graduated and went on with my career
that is now an unusual experience to a
ridiculous extent except among education
policy people there are going to be many
more students who leave high school and
go directly to work and start on a path
of learning from work that's going to
lead in very different directions then
my career has led and I don't believe
that we have done enough at the policy
level to explore what those different
pathways might look like and if you ask
employers industry leaders they tend to
agree with me on that we are not
thinking enough about middle-skill jobs
we are not thinking enough about
technical jobs below the level of
engineer and I think our society and its
policymakers really need to pay some
careful attention to that probably if if
and when we
to pay attention we will come upon the
tragic absence of apprenticeships in our
American society in Europe as many as
1/4 to 1/2 of any group of teenagers at
any point is pursuing an apprenticeship
which means that they are getting both
academic training and work training
while being paid by an employer they are
learning on the job to pursue a
particular career and that can be an
apprenticeship in software development
it can be a Prentice ship in Hotel
Management it can be an apprenticeship
in any number of things in the United
States we have shamefully convinced most
high school students that they either
need to go to Harvard or they need to go
to McDonald's and the truth is
significantly more complicated than that
in the middle of where job growth is
where there are jobs that are not being
filled today and too few people in our
public policy community are really
focused on what students who are going
to pursue a career as their pathway out
of poverty for example really need to be
getting from their education really need
to be getting from the public policy
people who are dedicated to creating
opportunities for them and allowing them
to pursue pathways that look nothing
like what we think is traditional
because the reality is the notion that
you go off to college live in a dorm go
to some football games graduate in four
years and go on with your life is a
persistent myth that has very little to
do with the lives of most people of
pursuing a degree after high school
right now and the sooner we get to the
point that we take the career side of
the college and career-readiness
equation much more seriously this better
off our society will be the fewer young
people we will have who are in a
position of not being in school or at
work and
the better off we will be in terms of
filling existing jobs requiring high
levels of skills for which there are no
employees to